[Musique]
nos vies
sur la somme de nos choix
et nous ne pouvons échapper au passé
Ethan cette mission
risque de vous coûter
très cher
le monde change
la vérité s'évapore la guerre est à nos
portes
ça fait longtemps cher ami
vous n'avez aucune idée de la puissance
que je représente
qui connaît votre histoire
quand on connaît la fin
écoutez-moi le monde entier sera contre
vous
son destin a été créé devant nous écrire
le vôtre si leur arrive quoi que ce soit
vous pourrez bien vous cacher n'importe
où je vous tuerai et ça c'est écrit
[Applaudissements]
Ethan quel est ton objectif
quel est ton objectif
ultime
[Musique]
vos vies contre toujours plus
à mes yeux que la mienne
aucune de nos vies ne doit compter plus
que cette mission je ne suis pas
d'accord